joining us now are Fox News contributors
Joe Concha and Charlie hurt gentlemen I
don't know if you've just been laughing
really hard there because that was just
so enjoyable and and really believable
or really that it's it it strikes even
more Joe at the legitimacy of the
government in that this is what you
would expect to see from you know State
television uh and Americans I I we don't
like it
um there's serious issues in this
country we want leadership uh and yet
there is with Drew Barrymore who I think
is probably a lovely woman I'm I'm glad
she got through a difficult childhood
and that she's you know contributing to
uh the American tax base here but what
do you what do you think about this kind
of uh approach he's having now on the
holiday
well I'm with you Drew Barrymore we all
love DT it came out 40 years ago just to
age ourselves completely but people
should understand that since the
midterms Tammy that what you just played
is literally the only sit-down
television interview that the president
of the United States has done to this
point isn't that incredible that Joe
Biden after the midterms does one
interview not with 60 minutes and not
with Brett Bear and not with the few
legitimate journalists that would
actually ask him good solid questions
but he goes to Drew Barrymore instead
and what that tells you is that his
handlers are petrified to put him in
front of anybody who will ask him about
for instance the U.S Southern border and
the catastrophe that's going on down
there nearly 5 million people entering
this country there are 27 U.S states
that have a lower population than 5
million a lower population than the
number of people have come in in the
first two years of this presidency
bottom line Tammy this is a president
when it comes to the Press who does
exactly what his handlers tell him he
takes orders he doesn't make orders the
question is right who's making the
orders to him you know excellent points
and Charlie at the same time we we've
we've found that about six percent of
the American people have no real grasp
of how serious the Border situation is
maybe this strategy is working for them
maybe this happy talk everything's fine
I'm you know he won the election on this
I'm the unifier is this a thing that
they should be doing because it seems to
be working at this point
oh I think politically it it it
definitely is working uh and it works as
long as you have the media uh behind you
ignoring a crisis the likes of which we
see at the border which is entirely uh
been manufactured by this man by this
man alone you know his predecessor
Donald Trump solved the immediate crisis
of the flow didn't didn't solve all the
problems of immigration in this country
but solved the immediate problem of the
flow of illegals coming into the into
the country and this man and that man
alone right there on screen unilaterally
decided to undo all of the policies of
the previous administration and hand the
entire border over to sex traffickers
and drug lords and he's perfect in human
traffickers he's perfectly content with
it that's what he wanted and that's what
he got and the media is perfectly happy
to to sort of cover for him but uh you
know and and you know Joe Biden is not
only infinitely more divisive than his
predecessor I think that we've never had
a president in history as divisive as
this man we've never had a president in
history who called half the country
semi-fascist or accused half the country
of being Bull Connor or Jim supporting
Jim Crow laws this is insane and now
that after his administration lied going
into the last election claiming that a
million jobs had been created when it
actually only ten thousand jobs had been
created and he's now going to blame
voters blame citizens the people he
supposedly works for who have decided
not to get get vaccinated or boosted and
blaming them for his failures his
economic failures it's just it it it's
beyond the payoff and it is uh you know
Joe it just beyond comprehension is
certainly this is the same guy that
stood in front of the uh the the Federal
Hall in Pennsylvania with the blood red
background round and why I'm wondering
at this point since he was so
comfortable doing that leading up to an
election and it wasn't just calling
Republicans names this was about whoever
voted for Trump were white supremacists
were the fascists and all of that so it
was actually it was half of this country
that he was smearing Beyond Republicans
why is he shifting right now why is he
pretending that he's is once again the
great unifier what does this say to you
I I don't think Tammy he's shifting at
all I think his handlers are shifting
the message perhaps and then he goes out
there you've seen anchor band right
whatever you put in the teleprompter
burgundy will read whatever you hand
this president to read he will read why
are they doing it why are they doing it
what is the strategy in all seriousness
what are they are they getting worried
I'm wondering if they're looking at the
nature of what's happening with
confidence and legitimacy if they're
thinking they went too far is that
possible
no I don't think so I think it's just a
spur of the moment type of thing where
Tammy we're we're near the holidays so
you send out the the unifying message uh
during the holidays but you know to
Charlie's point before that the White
House stood today uh behind calling the
Georgia law Jim Crow 2.0 this is what
this White House does they'll tell you
it's 85 degrees out right now in Chicago
Pittsburgh we're here in Jersey and do
so with a straight face you can present
indisputable facts like there was record
voter turnout and in two straight
Georgia elections since they changed
that voting law and they'll tell you no
no it's still suppression going on and
in Georgia it's as hard to vote as
swimming across the Atlantic Ocean and
instead the media is standing up and
doing their job and saying this isn't
only misleading it's an intentional lie
uh they just shrug along with it as if
they're in tacit agreement what this
White House is gentlemen thank you very
much Joe Concha Charlie heard I
appreciate you joining us tonight hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling and now analysis you will not
get it anywhere else